Mortal Kombat's back yeah dude fist bump
Mortal Kombat I suppose all of you know
I am a huge Mortal Kombat fan I've been
looking forward to this game since June
or you know 15 years because let's face
it a great Mortal Kombat game hasn't
come out since like more will combat 3 2
if you're a real purist and now they get
the new Mortal Kombat which is a
retelling of Mortal Kombat's 1 2 & 3
with the promise that it will feel
old-school and hold up in today's times
as a fighter and does it yeah it does
first of all the story mode I feel like
I can review this game as a movie if
you're a hardcore Mortal Kombat fan that
doesn't really like Mortal Kombat legacy
you like old-school Mortal Kombat lore
this mortal kombat game is the Mortal
Kombat story for you it retails Mortal
Kombat's 1 2 & 3 but does it in a way
that's kind of like Star Trek where it's
like a retelling with elements of hey we
got to change some [ __ ] it's really
badass it's really intriguing it's
really good some things you recognize
you're like oh yeah that's awesome I
forgot about that and other things are
new but for a good reason
like for Mortal Kombat 1 to an ultimate
Mortal Kombat 3 99.9% of the characters
are back like sub-zero scorpion Sonya
sector's Cyrax Jamie Lee Curtis all of
them the only ones that aren't back or
motaro although he's in the story mode
but you don't fight him unless he's in
the challenge tower or something in
which told my hair out kill myself and
reigned no one gives a [ __ ] about rain
he might be DLC later but seriously in
Mortal Kombat trilogy did anyone really
care about rain put the keyboard down
dude don't say yes I've heard some
people gripe and be like all compared to
Street Fighter for Marvel vs. Capcom 3
Mortal Kombat's just a joke shut up it
really is a solid fighter in this new
Mortal Kombat you string hits and
special moves based on what you want to
string you do a move it sets them up in
the air you can do another move on that
once you know the moves for the
characters you can really see how you
can string them together which means if
you have two friends and they each use
the same character they're going to use
the character differently I really like
that that's awesome you have your one
two three hit combos to set them up then
after that special moves go nuts and the
hits are just brutal the sound effects
are gratifying when you're fighting one
of the cyborgs like sector or Cyrax and
you're hitting them it sounds like
you're taking a baseball bat to a
garbage can it's awesome and there's
enough extra content in this game to
last you a while my friends and I for
hours were playing one-on-one versus
combat and we were like did yeah that's
right there's a there's a whole tag mode
in here and you play that feels a
hundred times more intense it's like two
games in one and the challenge Tower is
pretty fun but I'm on like challenge 50
of 300 so it has time to get
enough to make me want to kill myself
speaking to kill yourself the fatalities
are back and they are badass noob saibot
has a fatality my jaw drop all my
friends were like oh my god that's the
best fatality ever I gotta agree with
them but pretty much is until I saw like
three others that made us do the same
thing so fatalities are back and they're
really bloody and gory and azam no DC
characters allowed shank still has a
fatality though if you were disappointed
in Mortal Kombat vs. DC dewey's fatality
you'll like it and you'll thank them
NetherRealm Studios that is now online
modes really cool like king of the hill
mode which is pretty much recapturing
the arcade field the winner stays on and
challengers challenged him and then when
he loses that winner stays on another
challengers challenge him and you get
really nervous like when you're the next
one up and two people are fighting than
one loses and your avatar goes up and
he's your turn to fight I felt like I
was : safe for like a spelling bee or
something like I hope I don't screw this
up and what I don't like is it keeps
tabs or your wins and losses which can
be really cool if you're really good but
when you lose you feel like an [ __ ] I
don't want to know how bad I suck on
Mortal Kombat I just want to believe
that I'm the best Mortal Kombat and that
has ever lived and let me go on
blissfully believing that but now you
check your stats you're like oh gods
right I lost a lot of sex but when you
see someone who has a really hefty
winning streak online than you beat him
you're just like you just been caged
Johnny Cage with 80s hair but all in all
online mode recaptures a lot of the
arcade feel but nothing beats having a
person in the room to you know talk [ __ ]
to and be in prison the Crypt is back
and the thing I don't like about the
Crypt is you have to unlock the second
fatalities for characters in the crypts
I don't know if I like that because if
you screw up you get some concept art or
some [ __ ] in which case you're gonna go
in Google and find out where all the
cool stuff is anyway so to kind of think
what's the point at that point but it
still is cool to try and guess until you
you go on Google and yes Shao Kahn is
the boss and he is a dick he is the
cheapest son of a [ __ ] I've seen in
like a fighting game in years he was
kicking my ass I looked at my friend and
I was like I can be on a first date with
myself right now and not experience
something as cheap as that bastard right
there I mean ultimately you don't feel
accomplished when you beat him because
you find a really cheap ass thing to
spam on him and you just keep doing that
it doesn't really feel like skill at
that point and I got the PlayStation 3
version so of course I got to talk about
Kratos and he's not he's different he
doesn't play like any other characters
in the game so he's so different you're
like he's not that great why would I be
him and I could be like smoke and really
beat some ass Mortal Kombat is a fan
service to all Mortal Kombat fans who
love the first Mortal Kombat's and
weren't really satisfied with the next
you know all the rest so Mortal Kombat's
back the
storing the games awesome the fighting
system in the game is awesome the
fatalities in the game are awesome it is
the best Mortal Kombat that exists
there's just no denying that combos
built off of special moves not clunky as
combo systems that's awesome so if
you're a fan of fighting games or Mortal
Kombat go pick the game up right now
what are you waiting for why are you
still watching this unless you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more in which case click right here to
see more fatality